[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález es
preocupante la situación en nicaragua la
región de américa latina está muy atenta
a lo que día a día está sucediendo en
este país centroamericano en donde los
últimos 25 días o tal vez un poco más
han dejado 20 opositores al gobierno del
presidente daniel ortega arrestados son
muchos también los exiliados de este
país centroamericano 5 precandidatos
presidenciales han sido arrestados por
supuestamente conspirar contra los
intereses y la seguridad del país y
también por intentar organizar un
supuesto golpe de estado y también
fueron calificados por el gobierno de
ser criminales veamos quiénes son de
quienes se trata la primera en ser
arrestada el pasado 2 de junio fue
cristiana chamorro hija de la ex
presidenta de nicaragua violeta barrios
de chamorro según los sondeos de opinión
era la más popular de estos aspirantes a
la silla presidencial y tal vez será la
más popular para hacer la potencial
rival de ortega en esas elecciones que
están previstas para el 7 de noviembre
chamorro es acusada de lavado
de dinero a través de la fundación que
lleva el nombre de su madre también está
en prisión el exdiplomático arturo cruz
el politólogo
félix maradiaga y el economista juan
sebastián chamorro
tras casi un mes sin dar declaraciones a
los medios el presidente nicaragüense
daniel ortega esta semana dio unas
declaraciones habló de una supuesta red
de conspiraciones contra su gobierno
también habló sobre los opositores y
sobre los precandidatos detenidos ortega
dijo que se trata de un grupo que trata
de organizar un golpe de estado en su
país estas fueron sus palabras
escuchemos entonces que no estamos
juzgando
a políticos
no estamos jugando candidatos aquí se
está juzgando
a criminales que han atentado contra el
país contra la seguridad del país contra
la vida de los ciudadanos al intentar
nuevamente organizar otro 18 abril otro
golpe de estado y eso es lo que estamos
persiguiendo eso es lo que se está
investigando y eso es lo que se
castigara en su momento tal y como lo
mandan las leyes
no tienen el argumento desde el gobierno
desde el presidente daniel ortega pero
la situación en nicaragua va mucho más
allá de estas detenciones y de la
persecución son también las violaciones
a los derechos humanos la falta de
separación de las instituciones que
garantizan esas elecciones democráticas
en el mes de noviembre organismos
internacionales como la cdh han mostrado
su preocupación por la situación en este
país centroamericano veamos
asimismo ha venido denunciando la
prolongación del estado de excepción de
facto en el país en el que se mantiene y
ahora se ha intensificado el cierre de
los espacios democráticos bajo una
estrategia que busca impedir e inhibir
cualquier forma de manifestación
contraria al gobierno y que incluye la
aprobación de una serie de leyes
contrarias al derecho internacional de
los derechos humanos bueno pues así
están las cosas a grandes rasgos para
analizar este tema saludamos a xóchitl
ocampo ella es abogada periodista ex
diputada por el partido frente
sandinista de liberación nacional ella
se encuentra en managua la capital
nicaragüense también está con nosotros
noel vidaurre ls precandidato a la
presidencia de este país por el partido
alianzas ciudadanos por la libertad
también está en la capital nicaragüense
y también se encuentra con nosotros en
el estudio de france 24 jorge hurtado
periodista nicaragüense corresponsal de
france 24 allí en el centro américa en
managua también está con nosotros y
ustedes también hacen parte de este
debate son parte de la conversación
pueden dejar a través de las redes
sociales pueden dejar allí todos sus
comentarios
pregunta sus inquietudes las encuentran
en facebook y también estamos en twitter
y en instagram estamos como france24
s también sant y luego que es mi cuenta
personal dejen los comentarios con el
numeral el debate efe 24 tenemos en este
momento una encuesta en línea que ha
publicado el equipo de redes sociales de
france 24 en español y pueden responder
a la siguiente pregunta a menos de cinco
meses para las elecciones en nicaragua
el gobierno de daniel ortega ha ordenado
la detención de al menos 20 opositores
cree que la comunidad internacional
debería tener un papel mucho más activo
durante estos comicios generales que
están como ya les decía previstos para
el mes de noviembre pues tenemos el
contexto de los invitados y comienzo
entonces con nuestro invitado en el
estudio jorge hurtado para conocer en
detalle cómo es la situación allí en el
día a día en nicaragua en managua en la
capital jorge gracias por acompañarnos
hoy en el programa y cuéntenos cómo está
la situación en este momento en
nicaragua que se percibe en las calles
de la capital nicaragüense que dicen los
ciudadanos cuál es la percepción que hay
en cuanto a estas detenciones a lo que
está sucediendo
el gobierno y dejar a estas elecciones
bueno son tres años ya de crisis social
y política que se vive en el país que
inició precisamente en abril de 2018
tras una controversial reforma a la
seguridad social que hizo que muchas
personas salieran a las calles a
manifestarse la reforma incluía la
elevación de la pensión a los jubilados
y muchos jóvenes sobre todo lideraron
estas manifestaciones que fueron
brutalmente reprimidas hay datos de la
comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos de más de 326 muertes
documentadas es debido a la violencia
que se vivieron en esos meses en
nicaragua y que sin duda fue noticia y
muchos de ustedes también recordarán
pero luego de que se acallaron las
protestas a finales de 2018 la crisis se
prolongó una crisis no sólo de derechos
humanos
no también una crisis económica que el
año pasado se agravó con la pandemia del
coronavirus y ahora en 2021 nos
encontramos en un año en el cual se van
a realizar elecciones generales en donde
el mandatario daniel ortega se piensa a
reelegir por cuarta ocasión como
presidente en compañía de su esposa
quien también es vicepresidente del país
y con una oposición
la mayoría que surgió después de las
protestas de 2018 y otras que se han
sumado también un poco llamas
tradicionales pero que se han sumado a
estas convocatorias para participar en
las elecciones generales de noviembre
pero que todavía no logran ponerse de
acuerdo en medio de ese panorama confuso
político en el cual hay mucha
polarización entre los simpatizantes de
daniel ortega y del frente sandinista y
de los denominados azul y blanco que son
estas personas que salieron a
manifestarse en las protestas contra el
gobierno que mutaron primero fueron por
pedido de la reforma tributaria pero que
después solicitaban reformas
democráticas como elecciones justas
transparentes y observadas a nivel
internacional
bueno pues comenzamos con el análisis
con nuestros invitados allí desde
nicaragua gracias jorge y usted puede
intervenir cuando quiera aquí en el
programa y comienzo entonces con xóchitl
ocampo allí en managua o si usted nos
puede explicar qué es lo que intenta
hacer el gobierno de ortega deteniendo a
estos precandidatos deteniendo a
opositores claramente de la escena
política y opositores a su gobierno que
lo que intenta hacer el sandinismo
muy buenas noches quiero agradecerles la
participación que me brindan en este
programa y un saludo a la audiencia a
sus seguidores de las redes sociales yo
no puedo hablar a nombre del gobierno
porque no soy funcionaria del gobierno
soy una periodista y actualmente digo
ejerció el derecho y como ciudadana
militarmente pues me tomo la tarea de
aclararle al mundo aclararle a la
opinión internacional algunos conceptos
equivocados que tienen sobre la
situación que se está viviendo en
nuestra amada nicaragua precisamente
antes en la presentación que hacían a
esta entrevista estaba observando una
nota periodística que ustedes hacían
referencia y santiago decía una
situación preocupante que se vive para
la opinión internacional también hablaba
de 20 opositores arrestados hablaba de
exiliados hablaba de 5 precandidatos y
pide aclarando y sí ojalá me dé tiempo
para aclarar poco a poco esas dudas que
tienen hay años a nivel internacional
porque es lógico el que no está aquí no
sabe lo que está
y únicamente puede estar pecar por hacer
comentarios o decir cosas que no te
gustan porque no está aquí y nicaragua
pero quienes estamos aquí en nuestro
país estamos claros en la situación que
se está viviendo y no nos prestamos a
manipulación de medios que está
claramente demostrado se llamaban
independientes pero que de independiente
no tienen nada porque precisamente el
contexto que estamos viviendo nos deja
claro que son medios financiados por el
imperio norteamericano o llámense pues
por la agencia de exploración que
quieren llamar de eeuu
escucho si xóchitl pero pero vamos al
punto de la pregunta que le estoy
haciendo entonces que lo que intenta
hacer el gobierno yo sé que ustedes ya
no se aclaró usted no es funcionario del
gobierno pero desde su perspectiva como
entiende usted la situación que se ha
vivido en estos últimos 25 días perfecto
eso iba cuando habla de atr expositores
quiero decirle que en nuestra
constitución política nos dice en su
primer artículo que la independencia la
soberanía y la autodeterminación
nacional son derechos irrenunciables del
pueblo y fundamentos de la nación
nicaragüense toda la injerencia
extranjera en los asuntos internos de
nicaragua o cualquier intento de
menoscabar esos derechos atenta contra
la vida del pueblo es deber de todos los
nicaragüenses preservar y defender esos
derechos eso es lo que está pasando en
nicaragua el gobierno con sus
instituciones la policía nacional el
ministerio público y todo lo que nuestra
corte suprema de justicia a través de
los juzgados todo lo que
la institución las diferentes los
diferentes poderes del estado están
ejerciendo este mandato de la
constitución política que dice que le
gusta defender nuestra soberanía nuestra
autodeterminación y lo que está
ocurriendo en nicaragua es que se ha
destapado le decimos aquí la danza de
los millones se ha descubierto y logrado
es tremenda investigación es saber
quiénes son los que han recibido
millones pero millones de dólares a
través de la supuesta colaboración
norteamericana que lo único que buscaba
es nuevamente un intento de golpe porque
les recordamos tienen 2018 nicaragua
número un cáncer o intento de golpe pero
se ha alojado a través de
investigaciones determinar que estos
personajes no contentos con tus
desastres que ocasionaron en 2018
pretendían continuar con su intento
golpista con tal reacción se está
explicando la ley número 1055 que es una
ley que ha sido aprobada porque entre
asamblea nacional
a detener estos intentos golpistas que
pretenden desestabilizar porque lo
triste de autor es la consecuencia que
sufre el pueblo en cuanto a la pobreza
el desempleo parece estabilizar
económicamente en nuestro país que
también llevamos entonces lo que
pretendemos es que cuando pase
nuevamente los 2018 no va a volver a
pasar entiendo si tenemos un punto de
vista que piensa no él también allí en
managua que es lo que usted cree que
está sucediendo al interior del gobierno
que lo que busca el gobierno de daniel
ortega con estas detenciones con estas
leyes aprobadas y todo esto en un año
electoral
buenas tardes de santiago buenas tardes
a todos los televidentes de ese canal y
buenas tardes a corresponsable el mal
agua y una tarde a sochi el que está al
otro lado de la línea en el debate bueno
el primer gol yo creo que es importante
destacar la profunda crisis económica
política y social que vive el país y
realmente el ambiente electoral estar
sumamente restringido en nuestro país
hoy en día no se pueden hacer
manifestaciones políticas partidarias
para
destacar el partido político o candidato
en precandidato a la presidencia de la
república oa la diputación realmente la
crisis sí sí es profunda a escasos
cuatro meses de las elecciones realmente
no se respira un ambiente de fiesta
cívica un ambiente electoral en el que
la libertad de expresión política pueda
pueda darse en toda su magnitud el
gobierno de estado respectivamente
encarcelarlo ha conocido opositores
políticos al frente sandinista algunos
señores han disuelto de abril del 2018
otros del 18 2000 del 2018 para acá es
que sí
han encarcelado ya bastantes más de diez
quince opositores políticos
y algunos vecinos encarcelados y
notificados por el ministerio público
como investigados por el delito de
lavado de dinero de activos y bienes
otros han sido encarcelados con
el delito d
de la ley 10 55 contra la soberanía la
autodeterminación
y la paz de la sociedad nicaragüense
estos son básicamente los dos delitos
por los cuales han sido encarcelados
algunos opositores en el caso de que
quedara chamorro también ha sido acusada
por la fiscalía del delito de gestión de
un siglo y de falsedad ideológica
eso es a santiago la situación de
política actualmente y la verdad es que
el clima
que debería existir en un acepte
electoral próxima pues realmente no se
está dando y hay mucho temor hay que hay
que reconocer y destacar el temor de
muchos nicaragüenses de la inmensa
mayoría de por expresarse de poder
digamos
y esta política de proselitismo político
expresarse porque tiene miedo de ser
encarcelados bueno tienen ustedes las
dos caras de la moneda de dos
perspectivas de lo que de lo que sucede
allí en nicaragua jorge aquí en el
estudio desde su perspectiva entonces
para cerrar este este primer bloque
sobre el panorama general que lo que
intenta hacer el gobierno con estas
detenciones que lo que intenta hacer
como ya lo decían los invitados en este
año electoral eso siembra un mal síntoma
para la democracia en este país bueno de
retomó algunas palabras por ejemplo del
presidente de la asamblea nacional de
nicaragua gustavo por él manifestaba que
expresamente lo que querían realizar era
lo que buscan es crear un andamiaje
jurídico esas son sus palabras
específicas para tratar de defenderse
como ellos mencionan de este intento de
golpe de estado
o de actos de terrorismo como han
calificado a cualquier manifestación o
cualquier expresión que no vaya acorde a
las palabras del oficialismo como tal
entonces al crear este andamiaje se
desarrollaron varias reformas normativas
y leyes que se han creado de diciembre
de 2020 a este año como tal algunas
leyes como ya mencionamos la ley de
agentes extranjeros por ejemplo que
establece que cualquier persona que
reciba financiamiento de la cooperación
internacional de organismos no
gubernamentales pues podría ser
penalizado con cárcel inclusive o
considerado un agente extranjero y los
obliga a dar un reporte de todas sus
actividades también hay una ley de
ciberdelito que ha sido muy
controversial y nicaragua debido a que
menciona de que cualquier persona que
esté comunicando o dando a conocer
noticias que el gobierno considere falsa
podría también ser penalizado con multas
o hasta prisión la ley de defensa de
soberanía que califica o que usa este
lenguaje en el andamiaje público
jurídico de agente extranjero de
terrorista o golpista que son palabras
que ha usado el gobierno para referirse
específicamente a la oposición como tal
y que bajo esta ley es la que está
siendo procesado alguno de estos
candidatos o aspirantes presidenciales y
otros líderes opositores que surgieron
en 2018 y otros que ya existían también
hubo una reforma al código procesal
penal que pasa y está me parece muy
importante no que básicamente lo que
hizo fue ampliar el plazo de 48 horas a
90 días el tiempo que una persona debe
estar en prisión por bajo investigación
de cualquier delito y esta extensión en
el código procesal penal ha sido
impuesta a los candidatos aspirantes a
la presidencia que estaban al operándose
en bloques opositores
justamente meses antes de la elección
todo hace indicar que existe algún tipo
de inhibición para que esta persona pues
no participen en la elección electoral
claro para que luego el tiempo no les
alcance para poder desarrollar sus
candidaturas tal beso o para que no
puedan pues simplemente participar en
este proceso electoral
xóchitl precisamente le quería preguntar
por este proceso electoral de acuerdo a
estas leyes usted es abogada nos puede
explicar un poco mejor en detalle
no piensa usted que esto está sembrando
un poco un mal síntoma para esas
elecciones presidenciales de noviembre
hay de verdad garantías institucionales
y garantías en el escenario político
para llevar a cabo esto este proceso
electoral
a cinco meses de las elecciones pero me
da risa porque aquí en el 2018 que se
intentaban por presentado decían
queremos elecciones ya y no se dieron en
ese momento resulta que en 2021 y
todavía no están listos todavía no están
preparados para las elecciones y contó
que querían que las elecciones pueden el
2018 esta gente no está pista está
preparada sencillamente por varios
factores uno todos quieren ser cantidad
me dicen que están presos 5
precandidatos porque que todos quieren
ser candidatos a la presidencia no sé
también han de poner de acuerdo no se
terminan de unir no terminan de formar
siquiera un partido unt en la pregunta
de qué partido político son y resulta
que eso es algo que le llaman fácilmente
precandidatos ni siquiera tienen un
partido político para ganar las
elecciones en nicaragua o en parque en
cualquier parte del mundo se necesita
primero tener un partido político luego
una casilla que es en la que el pueblo
vaya depositar su voto pero ninguno de
estos personajes desde aquí cualquiera
se llama precandidato ninguno estos
personajes han sido inscritos no tienen
siquiera un partido
político y el nicaragüense aquí lo sabe
porque no te risa que todos son
precandidatos pero al final de cuentas
no tienen una casilla no tienen un
partido político inclusive aquí tanto
doctor vida o rey él me lleva
probablemente el doble de edad pero
desde que yo tengo uso de razón sé que
él ha sido candidato ha participado en
cantidades de elecciones como un partido
conservador y ahora es nuevamente
precandidato no sé en qué casilla va
creo que vamos a ponerle hay seis
partidos políticos ya legalmente
inscritos que cumplen con los requisitos
que cumplen la ley y que están inclusive
ya nombrando a su a su personal para que
defiendan el voto quién es el pueblo que
organiza su dirección de nicaragua el
doctor noel vidaurre lo sabe porque él
acá en cantidades de procesos
electorales hacia la cantidad tu alcalde
a presidente ahora creo que nuevamente
va a correr y está en todo su derecho
pero eso sí aquí no cualquier
delincuente puede querer ser presidente
de nicaragua tiene que respetar la ley y
tiene sobre todo que tener la moral para
poder ser candidato y no ser una persona
que ha sido financiada por un gobierno
extranjero ha recibido millones y eso se
está demostrando se ha levantado siglo
bancario a la vista bancaria y muchos de
estos personajes están presos empezando
por la señora chamorro tiene millones en
su cuenta entonces aquí para y en
cualquier parte del mundo y que quiera
participar debe de tener un partido
político en castilla y que el pueblo
pudiera votar por el presente mes y
desde su perspectiva el presidente
daniel ortega tiene la moral para
aspirar a una nueva reelección para un
quinto mandato aquí el pueblo dice que
el comandante daniel ortega y yo me sumo
a eso ha sido el mejor presidente de
nicaragua en la historia y eso lo vemos
con los resultados de su gestión de
gobierno
el coronavirus que por decirle en el
concejo el que nos encontramos ha sido
una pandemia que nicaragua es un país en
desarrollo ha logrado controlar de
manera significativa y ejemplar aquí esa
pandemia ha sido controlada gracias a
una gestión del gobierno que de premio
se preparó con en la inversión pública
en la salud
y cada uno en seis bolsas de la salud
gratuita en otros países del mundo
inclusive el más democrático del mundo
eeuu
mucha gente se muere en las puertas de
un hospital porque no tienen para poner
panel de salud entonces el pueblo aquí
dice que el comandante también puede ser
candidato porque el pueblo primero
quiere votar por él y segundo porque su
gestión del gobierno refleja que los
resultados han sido en beneficio de la
mayoría del pueblo y nicaragua
noel su opinión al respecto varios
puntos la moral que tiene daniel ortega
para aspirar a un quinto mandato y las
garantías que hay para presentarse a
estos comicios presidenciales usted
precisamente también es un precandidato
y usted si cree que hay garantías hay
una independencia institucional
electoral que le garantice a usted
aspirar a estos comicios
en ese sentido el primer barco realidad
al señor ocampo que yo solamente yo cali
a todas las presencias república una vez
nunca he sido candidato alcalde nunca si
yo quería diputado fue diputado por
candidato a presidente pero no creación
más que una vez candidato presidencial
republicano que yo candidato alcalde
seguramente ésta está confundida eso por
aclaración arma al señor ocampo para que
para que manejen en la cultura política
en segundo lugar yo creo que yo creo que
donde sostiene dice es que el pueblo
nicaragüense considera que daniel ortega
ha sido el mejor presidente yo creo que
las encuestas que se han hecho y por
algunos encuestadores internacionales
dicen todo lo contrario
missair que su nivel de aceptación por
el desempeño de su gobierno es bastante
bajo verdad esto no concuerda lo que
dice el señor ocampo con lo que lo que
dice la mayoría del pueblo nicaragüense
en todo caso
pues no supongo que las elecciones del 7
de noviembre en las cuales estoy seguro
pero ustedes se van a presentar
nuevamente como candidato por su partido
pues van a decir si es verdad no es
verdad lo que dicen las encuestas o lo
que dice la señora ocampo yo estoy
seguro que una fuerza política como la
nuestra la de ciudadano por la libertad
derrotar a la derecha en cuanto a las
garantías
en santiago preguntaba en cuanto a la
garantía para unas elecciones libres y
transparentes pues tengo que decir que
realmente no hay garantías como las
entendemos en los estándares
internacionales en primer lugar no se ha
permitido o no se está permitiendo la
observación internacional en segundo
lugar nos está permitiendo tampoco a la
observación nacional en tercer lugar
todo el magistrado del consejo supremo
electoral acaba de ser electo hace pocas
semanas todos pertenecen al partido
frente sandinista de manera que
obviamente todos van a llegar ahí a
defender a su partido defenderá no a
defender la verdadera aplicación de la
constitución y las leyes de la ley
electoral y las demás leyes verdad que
es la obligación de un magistrado en un
consejo su personal que supone ser un
hombre independiente supone ser un
hombre apegado a la constitución ya la
ley de manera que no podemos decir es en
tercer lugar
es lo que se llama el padrón electoral
santiago yo no sé si ustedes están en
colombia están en el mismo término pero
en paro electorales como lo usan ok
entonces el pañuelo aquí se ha inventado
una cosa que es absolutamente absurda
nacional e internacionalmente y es que
hay un padrón pasivo y un padre un
activo que significa ello significa que
un nicaragüense que no ha votado en las
últimas dos elecciones nacionales
sale del padrón lo pone un padrón pasivo
y lo puede votar en la elección resultó
supongamos que estaba viviendo por el
poder en las últimas dos elecciones por
poner un ejemplo o no le dio la gana
será ocupado por que sencillamente aquí
el voto de libre el voto no es
obligatorio en otros países entonces
sencillamente no no fue a votar porque
no tuvo tiempo porque contaremos o
porque no encontró ningún candidato que
el ejemplo la obtención esa persona que
no fuera
de su facultad de su derecho y otra
obligación de ir a votar porque no voto
nos duele eso por supuesto
algo contrario a la garantía de la
libertad que debe tener una elección
libre y transparente
se tiene que se tiene que depurar y todo
el mundo que tenga una identidad de
nicaragua tiene derecho a votar así no
he votado en las últimas cinco
elecciones anteriores porque el derecho
está consagrado en la constitución y así
la señora ocampo
menciones de constitución como la piedra
sagrada pues obviamente la constitución
que es la piedra sagrada si no tenemos
el derecho de ir a votar y no hacer una
exclusión de que si votar y no el último
globo tanto jorge que tan popular es
daniel orte es actualmente para los
nicaragüenses que tan popular sigue
siendo dentro de esas masas populares
que fueron los que inicialmente votaron
por él le dieron la oportunidad de
regresar otra vez al poder después de
haber estado en la década de los 80
bueno es una pregunta compleja porque la
encuesta e inclusive que existen en el
país son bastantes cuestionada debido a
estos mismos resultados
ortega retorno al poder en 2007 con un
35 por ciento de votos y efectivamente a
medida que pasaban los años y que la
economía iba mejorando tenía cierta
popularidad siempre en sus bases y
algunas encuestas lo apuntaban como un
mandatario popular sin embargo después
del estallido social ocurrido en 2000
8 creo que la mayor encuesta ha sido las
cientos de personas que salieron a la
calle a manifestarse pidiendo su salida
pidiendo reformas democráticas y
demostrando su inconformidad con su
gestión y eso ha sido una permanente
durante los últimos años en los últimos
tres años han sido marcados por esta
polarización política en donde existen
muchos seguidores del presidente la
mayoría inclusive que demuestran su
apoyo en las calles hacia él son
trabajadores del estado eso ha quedado
evidenciado y documentado ampliamente
sin embargo la contraparte que no tiene
ningún vínculo con el estado como tal
pues sigue demostrando su inconformidad
ahora con muchísimo temor debido a esta
gran cantidad de arrestos
para el tramo final de este programa
quiero preguntarle a nobel qué va a
suceder con esta coyuntura que está
viviendo nicaragua muy puntual por favor
va a seguir la comunidad internacional
ejerciendo presión como ha intentado a
través de organismos como la
organización de estados américanos que
hicieron una votación allí muy
controversial la votación de argentina y
méxico pero que cree usted que va a
pasar
yo creo que lo que va a pasar es que van
a haber elecciones del 7 de noviembre
que lo más importante es la presión
nacional la presión que hagamos los
nicaragüenses para que aquí hayan
elecciones libres transparentes y sobre
todo que se cuenten los votos 11 y que
haya una decisión de las autoridades
electorales en el sentido de que quien
tenga más votos del pueblo ese es el
ganador y el presidente de nuestro país
eso es lo fundamental yo estoy seguro
que ese no va a permitir esta vez el
audi pero lo más importante y la mayor
garantía para que no haya frank
que vamos a salir a votar masivamente
los nicaragüenses si salimos a votar la
mayoría inversa de la nicaragüense que
nos oponemos al régimen dictatorial de
ariel ortega no hay manera se pueden
robar las elecciones el 7 de noviembre y
eso es lo que estamos presionando al
interno de no verlos por un tipo que
salgamos a votar todos los nicaragüenses
a demostrar nuestro refugio y nuestro
rechazo al gobierno dictatorial de
janiero de seguir su opinión para la
misma preventa muy puntual por favor
tengo plena fe convicción de que el
pueblo nicaragüense va a celebrar este
próximo 7 de noviembre elecciones libres
soberanas que va a ser una fiesta fue
una fiesta del pueblo en la que se va a
respetar la voluntad popular ya en la
que el pueblo va a salir a votar y a
darle en su respaldo al candidato que le
guste a la cantidad que considere que va
a cumplir con sus promesas que va a
significar un mejoras para nuestro país
que continuar por esa senda de las
mejorías económicas sociales esas
reivindicaciones sociales yo sí quisiera
básicamente también hablar sobre la
presión de la oea a los nicaragüenses en
la olla no no me hace ninguna presión
sencillamente esta organización está tan
desprestigiada que realmente ya ni
respeto tiene y además estamos claros
aquí los nicaragüenses que la obra es un
instrumento lamentablemente se convirtió
en un instrumento de los eeuu que son
quienes le pagan eso lo tenemos claro y
yo creo que nadie se engaña con eso y
que por ejemplo la señora que hablaba al
inicio de este programa en
representación de la cdh
y respaldó con qué autoridad hablan de
nicaragua si sabemos muy bien que han
sido ciegos ante la situación de
colombia en chile en las situaciones que
se ha dado en diferentes países no mira
nada no pasa nada y colombia no pasa
nada en chile no pasa nada en perú que
se quieren robar las elecciones no pasa
nada en esos países están solo encima de
nicaragua en tantos encima de es el
gobierno que significa una amenaza para
el gobierno de eeuu porque
definitivamente es un gobierno de
izquierda un gobierno socialista y eso
es lo que nos quiere eeuu por eso es que
la oea de esmera se ensaña alimentar
queriendo presionar pero aquel que
decide como dice el doctor vidal de el
pueblo nicaragüense este conjunto va a
decidir quién va a gobernar en este país
en los próximos años de gobierno y por
cierto es el pueblo organizado el que va
a llevar a cabo sus elecciones y gracias
a xóchitl ya no el en la ciudad de
managua gracias también jorge por haber
estado aquí con nosotros en el programa
en el debate ustedes puede seguir
dejando sus preguntas y sus comentarios
a través de las redes sociales gracias
por la sintonía gracias por la
preferencia
con nosotros
[Música]